good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that great thing that you have
inside you explode out into the world
and have a big impact so to help you on
your journey today's message is you're
different over to you Les Brown I'm
saying this is the time more than ever
that you want to begin to inoculate
yourself with positive words coming to
conventions showing up on meetings being
on the calls to make yourself
unstoppable to get out of your mind the
polluting negative thoughts that's
causing most people to go through life
being stuck because they are volunteer
victims somebody said that many people
died aged 25 and don't get buried until
they're 65 because they got so much
garbage in their minds you are here
because you've got a clear vision of
what you want and where you're going
give yourselves a round of applause come
on bring energy level up yes yes you
want more you want more you're different
you're different than everybody else
don't worry if they don't get it don't
try and convince people to do this
business a person convinced against
their will is of the same opinion still
you are not like everybody else you can
walk outside and find pigeons but if
you're looking for Eagles it's going to
take you a minute you are different it's
lonely at the top how many of you know
it's lonely at the top raise your hands
it's lonely at the top but you eat
better that's what I'm talking about
you're different
one great entrepreneur said I choose not
to be a common man it's my right to be
uncommon if I can I'll seek opportunity
not security I do not wish to be a kept
citizen humbled and dull by having the
state look after me I want to take the
calculated risk to dream
bill to fail and to succeed I refuse to
live from hand to mouth I prefer the
challenges of life to the guaranteed
existence the thrill of fulfillment to
the still calm of utopia
I will never cower before a master nor
bin to any threat it's my heritage to
stand erect proud and unafraid the face
the world boldly and say this I have
done you showed up because you're
building a business that you can stand
and say I did this I did this this is my
dream give yourselves a round of
applause yes yes yes your difference is
how you're going to win whatever makes
you you is how you're gonna win is how
you're gonna stand out is what's gonna
attract like-minded people to you and
that is how you're gonna have ultimate
success if people cannot tell the
difference between you and somebody else
then you're gonna lose it's just gonna
be based off a price if I can't tell the
difference between your service or your
product and 100 other people who are
selling exact same thing why would I
ever why would I ever pick you I'm gonna
pick the person whose name I recognize
whose commercials I've seen or who
charges the lowest price right like at
the end of the day if I can't tell the
difference at all you're gonna go with
the lowest price and that is that is a
race to the bottom that is not the game
that you want to play and this is your
biggest advantage as an entrepreneur
like this is how you beat the big
companies you're not gonna beat them on
your name recognition and on your
branding you're gonna beat them off of
your story and so many entrepreneurs are
just trying to look like big companies
your website you copy up big companies
you want to look professional you you
know have similar artworks everybody
else and it's not that you need to be
unprofessional we need to be you we need
to let this thing inside you come out I
need to know your story to feel your
passion you're gonna win because I feel
the connection to you as a human being
for why you're starting this business as
opposed to working for some big company
why would I ever go to some big company
let's we're not really gonna care about
me I'm gonna come to you because I know
you I feel like I can connect with you
and a lot of you guys comment on my
videos and you connect with my story
even though I know anything about you
yet or a little bit in the comments
right by creating content whether that's
through social media or on your website
or in all your marketing materials
telling the story creating content
allows people to feel like they know you
and when people feel like they know you
they're gonna want to do business with
you this is why I believe it's really
important to figure out what your one
where it is that's why I wrote the book
like what are you staying for as a human
being and then bring that to your
business I'm about believe and so all of
my videos are about believe it's always
positives I was encouraging I believe we
haven't seen potential my my goal is
always to help bring that out in you
with every piece of content that I make
I don't always succeed not every video
is fantastic but I'm trying that's the
intention I never put out a video that
is negative or attacking or saying this
person sucks or people fighting against
each other it just goes against my core
values and not everybody likes that
that's okay like lots of people don't
like the message believe lots of people
are negative and haters and the little
maim and they're you know they want
content of people fighting with each
other they don't resonate with my
channel that's okay they go somewhere
else there's lots of places to go to on
YouTube and on the internet to find
people hating on each other the people
who come to me who watch my videos you
guys are the ones who like the message
who believes like the positive uplifting
courageous message and that's who I end
up attracting the people who like that
like me more
and some attracting people who like me
who have the same kind of values who
want to make a positive impact in the
world
and so that's what I want for you I want
people to be able to recognize you can
recognize the difference between me and
somebody else me and another youtuber
pick pick another youtuber that you like
and you put us against each other just
in terms of values and kind of content
we create you can tell the difference
you can explain what I do and you can
explain what they do how would people
explain what you do and why it's
different I want people to love your
message or self eliminate say you know
what that believe is a stupid message I
don't want any part of it awesome great
like go off and do your thing no problem
just don't hang around us and leave hate
right and so figuring out what your one
word is what your most important core
value with and then bringing that out
into your business it's not a word for
your business is a word for you
personally that you bring to everything
that you do so you can attract the
people who feel the same way and those
people will love you and they'll buy
more from you and and they'll pay higher
prices for you and they'll refer their
friends to you
you need to have that word of mouth or
furl marketing in any entrepreneurial
company because we can't afford to take
out Super Bowl commercials you being you
recognizing your difference and loving
that and bringing that out and being
courageous enough to say here's what I
stand for here's the mark that I want to
make here's why I started my company
it's scary right because people will
judge you and that's okay but it also
shows how you're different and those
people who love that message will flock
to you and you get to be around
customers employees partners suppliers
investors who believe the same thing
that you believe who love your
difference and want to be a part of it
but if you don't have clarity on that
then you just look like everybody else
and it's a race to the bottom and you
competing on price
so the question day today is I'm curious
what makes you different if you know
your one word what's your one word if
there's something else about you your
value is something like what makes you
you that you want to bring to your
business that makes you different that
some people will love and some people
will hate what is that
leaving the comments below I'm really
curious if I know I also want to give a
quick shot at to Shauna Fitzpatrick
Shauna thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book taking that picture
posted to Instagram as well
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
do you remember the audition when you
first met de niro that was yeah I mean
that was one of those incredible
auditions that came around that I
suppose every kid had been waiting for
for a long period of time because it's
just not that often that you get a
starring role above Robert De Niro in
this incredible you know screenplay and
was a you know Ellen Barkin and Michael
Keaton Jones and was just everyone was
sort of feeding for this role and I I
got down I suppose to the final five and
there was like a last sort of day
Toby was there and I I do remember
thinking to myself I got to do something
I got to do something to stand out and
in the audition there was art lence and
Michael Keaton Jones art Lata's that was
the producer and DeNiro and I remember
there was a mustard jar scene and he had
to jam a mustard jar in my eye
repeatedly it was an abuse scene and the
script so didn't call for it but I got
up and I he said now is it empty is it
empty and I got up and I screamed Oh
like completely unnecessary but I
screamed in his face and i sat there you
know with my head you know looking like
a red tomato and and and everyone
started laughing at me and then the
entire room de niro everybody was in
hysterics i sat there frozen's thinking
oh my god I just screwed this entire
yeah and I just sat there frozen and
then you know Bob and traditional DeNiro
fashioned kind of just looked at me with
good
and and and then you know we carried on
doing the scene and I think I actually
had dinner with DeNiro recently and he
told me no I was the one who said I was
the one who said you should get the get
the job first mention of George Michael
in my life was by Mark Dean who ran this
little label called inner vision and he
said I've signed an act that you're
going to love and they're gonna be huge
and they're called Wham they're called
Wham
he said yes they're called Wham they
were starting to get noticed on the UK
music scene but what was it about Wham
that made them stand out from the
competition I think to be honest with
you great songs and you know such a
formula that we didn't realize we had
you know these two young boys doing this
kind of Butch Cassidy and Sundance thing
but in a very kind of camp way and there
I think there was something about the
fact that it was all very obvious that
our our relationship as friends was real
there was some kind of chemistry between
us that we absolutely hadn't counted on
you know but the world seemed to see
pretty quickly thing about life that
that if I could tell a young person is
everything that you get picked on or you
feel makes you weird is is essentially
what's gonna make you sexy as an adult
exactly because
I
I just you know I mean
III got a big nose but I rock it no III
seriously though I you know everything
you know when you're a kid I think you
try so hard to fit in and when you get
older you realize that fitting in isn't
really the thing that's more interesting
you know being your own person and being
an individual I would not be here if I
would have listened to the kids who told
me I was a terrible singer and I was a
[ __ ] and you know other things that
they would say to me you know it's be
different be different if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or so it
would be kind of like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details